je sais pas vous mais pour moi la vie
c'est comme une formation continue
on apprend tous les jours de nos
expériences
encore faut-il être attentif et retenir
chaque leçon le long du voyage d'ici
quelques semaines
je vais avoir 40 ans c'est l'âge
paraît-il où commence à regarder dans le
rétroviseur et on commence à se poser de
bonnes questions
vous savez toutes ces questions
existentielles autour des choix qu'on a
fait des actes qu'on a pu poser pour ma
part je dois vous dire que je suis
vraiment fier d'être ici parce que
trente ans en arrière
je n'imaginais pas une seule seconde
tout le potentiel que j'avais en moi
j'ai grandi avenue montagne l'une des
plus belle avenue du monde à paris mes
parents étaient gardien d'immeuble on
vivait à quatre dans une loge de 40
mètres carrés
il n'y avait pas de chambre autrement
dit on dormait tous dans la même pièce
et je me rappelle encore jouer avec des
enfants dans l'immeuble qui
appartenaient tous à des familles de
millionnaires dans des appartements
totalement disproportionnée au vu de
notre loge et puis retourner me glisser
dans mes draps en essayant de ne
réveiller personne alors j'ai eu une
scolarité pas comme les autres dès la
primaire on diagnostique enfant
dyslexique et 10 orthographique
alors très honnêtement il n'était pas
utile de mettre une étiquette sur le dos
parce que je voyais bien que j'étais le
seul dans la classe affaires 60 fautes
d'orthographe
élève dissipé manque de concentration
la tête dans les étoiles et j'imagine
qu'elle a sûrement dans le public qui
vont se reconnaître
j'étais à côté de la fenêtre proche du
radiateur et je regardais la vie à
l'extérieur et j'imaginais la vie à
l'extérieur
j'imaginais une école dans la lequel je
me sens bien
finalement une école qui me comprennent
je l'appelle l'école de la vie ce qui
est très amusant c'est que 30 ans après
j'ai réalisé un siège ou qui porte le
même nom l'école de la vie une
génération pour tout changer je me
rappelle intérieurement je me posais
tout un tas de questions je me disais
mais pourquoi c'est si simple pour les
autres alors que pour moi ça semblait
tellement compliqué et pourtant je
faisais vraiment beaucoup d'efforts et
puis progressivement
je me suis dit que je devais vraiment
être différent et j'ai cultivé cette
différence en réalité j'ai fait pitre à
l'école
donc je me suis vraiment bien amusé pour
moi la vie elle était à l'extérieur
elle n'était pas posé sur une chaise
force et à écouter des enseignants qui
avait honnêtement beaucoup de mal à
retenir mon attention
ma mère elle bienveillante a essayé de
m'emmener voir tout un tas de
spécialistes mais à chaque fois je ne
comprenais pas ce que je faisais ici et
y avait pas vraiment de solution à
l'horizon et un jour un miracle se
produit
notre classe fait partie d'un programme
scolaire qui consiste à nous faire
partir un mois aux etats-unis dans une
famille d'accueil tout en continuant
notre scolarité dans une école
américaine
j'ai à l'époque dix ans et ce voyage a
transformé ma vie
je commençais tout doucement à
apercevoir que c'est par l'expérience
que j'allais apprendre des choses j'ai
découvert un univers qu'on appelle notre
moi intérieur
et puis depuis plus de 25 ans maintenant
je voyage à travers le monde
je prends le tout le temps vint le temps
tous les ans de partir au moins une fois
seul avec mon sac à dos pour découvrir
un pays ça peut être très bien aussi en
france parce que je trouve que c'est le
meilleur outil en développement
personnel pourra prendre sur soi pour
apprendre sur les autres pour apprendre
sur la vie tout simplement
et je me rappelle à cette époque mon
frère à l'ingénieuse idée de me faire
découvrir le kung fu
cet art martial millénaire je vais
tomber dans la marmite à l'âge de 12 ans
et je vais y consacrer plus de 14 ans de
ma vie
pour moi les arts martiaux sont de
véritable école de la vie on y apprend
l'endurance la persévérance la souplesse
d'esprit mais aussi de corps on y
apprend le respect de l'autre mais aussi
le respect de soi et puis finalement on
développe une certaine confiance en soi
cette confiance justement que j'avais
perdu à l'école je les retrouvais dans
les voyages dans les arts martiaux pour
être sacré en 99 champion de france
alors dans une société qui nous
conditionnent et qui nous fait croire
que c'est par les diplômes ou qu'on va
réussir notre vie je suis les conseils
bienveillants de mes parents et
poursuivre mes études pour aller
jusqu'au bac
je vais me prendre à deux reprises et
finalement je me résigne sous les bons
conseils de mon directeur de l'époque
qui vous convoque dans son bureau qui me
dit sous un temps record monsieur perron
on ne servira à rien dans notre société
vous allez terminer ce dif
merci et donc j'ai essayé de vaquer à ce
qui me fait vraiment vibrer découvrir la
vie par l'expérience
j'ai alors 19 ans et je décide de
découvrir le monde du travail
je deviens facteurs adjoints de sécurité
veilleur de nuit barman serveur et puis
finalement la société est tellement
puissante qu'elle conditionne tellement
que je sens qu'il faut que je poursuive
des études il faut qu'ils aient
absolument que j'ai un diplôme si je
veux aller beaucoup plus loin
autrement dit réussir ma vie alors je
vais passer un bts action commerciale en
alternance mais qui n'aboutira pas vous
vous rappelez la prophétie du directeur
et bien va s'accomplir
ma mère et moi sommes obligés de partir
du jour au lendemain notre loge et on se
retrouve effectivement sans domicile
j'ai à l'époque 21 ans on est en plein
hiver et je décide malgré tout
d'accueillir cette expérience et de me
débrouiller par moi même plus de six
mois à essayer de savoir où dormir où
manger où prendre une douche et en même
temps six mois où je vais développer une
volonté une force comme un optimisme
vraiment à toute épreuve et donc en
parallèle de ça je suis embauché dans
une entreprise donc en alternance et j
révèle certaines de mes excellence je
m'aperçois que je suis bon en tant
qu'homme de communication et que j'ai
une certaine facilité à fédérer des gens
autour de moi je vais alors me lancer à
l'âge de 23 ans
j'ai voler de mes propres ailes et j'ai
créé mon entreprise
alors vous allez rigoler mon bureau une
chambre de bonne de 10 mètres carrés au
sixième étage sans ascenseur
j'ai pas de diplôme tu pas d'argent mais
il ya quelque chose en moi qui me dit
que c'est juste c'est cette petite voix
cet instinct cette intuition tue pas si
ça vous parle mais moi ça me parle
depuis que je suis tout petit
et donc je décide de la suivre et qu'on
trouve contre toute attente
finalement ça va fonctionner donc
pendant deux ans je vais galérer va pas
être évident mais tout ce que j'ai
appris dans les arts martiaux savoir la
volonté et la persévérance cultiver mon
corps et mon esprit
tout ça ça va m'aider à tenir bon et 16
ans après me voici un nouveau lisible
voici ici alors pas en tant que simple
chef d'entreprise mais en tant que
réalisateur et producteur maintenant de
deux films et bientôt en tant qu auteur
d'un livre
alors moi qui me disait que le monde du
cinéma était réservé au monde du cinéma
au vu des budgets tellement important
que nécessite la réalisation d'un seul
film je réalise et produit deux films
moi l'enfant dyslexique 10
orthographique 3 mandine nul en
orthographe
la tête dans les étoiles je crée en 2003
la première agence de communication
dédiée aux thérapeutes et j'entame donc
l'écriture de mon premier livre je me
rappelle plus petit est tombé sur une
citation qui m'a vraiment inspirée une
citation de gandhi qui dit soit le
changement que tu veux voir dans le
monde
cette phrase est encore aucun dre dans
mon bureau parce que pour moi elle
résume tout nous avons tous la
possibilité de réaliser nos rêves
si on s'en donne les moyens et si notre
énergie est focalisée alors depuis de
nombreuses années je consacre mon
énergie à l'éducation
je suis convaincu que tout part de là il
ya cinq ans en arrière j'ai écrit un
article où je donnais ma vision d'une
école nouvelle une proposition pourri
pour créer une école nouvelle
trois mois après sa publication je
recevais plus de 600 email de personnes
qui voulaient elles aussi participé à la
création de cette école
à l'époque je n'avais encore jamais
organisé l'événement et je me dis tiens
je vais organiser un pique nique géant
et je vais proposer à toutes ces
personnes qu'on se retrouve
et qu'on puisse tous parlé de ce projet
d'ouverture d'école nouvelle ça a été
une journée magique on s'est retrouvé
sur le plateau du larzac
on était bien 600 personnes et l'année
d'après ce pique nique s'est transformée
en festival et on est passé de 600
personnes à dix mille personnes
je me dis très souvent on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par ce que par soi même
quelques années après je me dis qu'il
est vraiment nécessaire aussi de fédérer
les professionnels dans le monde de
l'éducation
il ya tellement d'innovation qu'on n'est
pas au courant ou les médias ne
s'intéressent pas donc du coup je décide
d'organiser un congrès et puis là
dernièrement je réalise la suite du film
c'est quoi le bonheur pour vous qui
s'appelle donc l'école de la vie une
génération pour tout changer alors vous
pouvez peut-être vous demandez mais
comment j'ai fait par exemple pour
réaliser un film
j'en reviens encore à cette petite voix
j'ai suivi une petite voix une intuition
un instinct on l'appelle comme on veut
mais qui m'a poussé pendant quatre ans à
partir dans plus de 25 pays et a
interviewé plus de 1500 personnes autour
d'une seule question c'est quoi le
bonheur pour vous je ne maîtrisais aucun
outil aux vidéos je n'avais pas d'argent
pas de l'équipe de tournage j'ai
commencé avec un téléphone portable
et pourtant j'ai écouté cette voie un an
après sa sortie en 2017
c'est déjà plus de cinq cent mille
personnes qui ont vu le film alors je
pense que j'ai bien fait de l'écouté une
fois de plus cette petite voix vous
savez cette petite voix qui me guide
justement qui guide mes pas depuis ma
tendre enfance
moi je l'appelle l'intuition et j'ai le
sentiment qu'on nous apprend pas
justement à cultiver notre intuition
on nous apprend pas nous connecter à soi
on nous apprend pas à se connecter à nos
émotions à les comprendre on nous
apprend pas à développer notre patience
la persévérance comprendre tous les
mécanismes qui nous entourent et qui
fait qu' on est tous interconnectés nous
en tant qu'être vivant
on voit bien que l'intellect est mis en
avant et le développement de l'être est
mis de côté
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'hommes et de femmes qui pensent
différemment que les enjeux soient
sociétaux et environnementaux politiques
de l'heure de la santé de
l'agroalimentaire de l'éducation on a
besoin d'hommes et de femmes qui pensent
différemment et c'est possible pour moi
un être épanoui c'est une personne qui
s'est profondément ce qu'elle peut
apporter de mieux au bien commun et à
notre planète
c'est une personne qui est connecté à
ces excellences vous savez c'est ce qui
est tellement simple pour une personne
est beaucoup plus compliqué pour une
autre c'est une personne qui vit le flou
autrement dit quand nos valeurs sont en
accord avec notre métier notre job nous
en tant qu'adulte c'est d'accompagner
les enfants justement à être c'est de ne
pas les imposer de rentrer dans un moule
qui ne leur correspond pas et c'est de
développer des méthodes d'apprentissage
accessible aux huit formes
d'intelligence alors je continue de
rêver
je rêve d'une école je rêve d'une école
de la vie une école en pleine nature
dans laquelle on pourrait apprendre la
vie à prendre par l'expérience dans un
contexte intergénérationnel et au
contact de la vie réelle c'est pas une
auto pitou ce ça et tout ceci possible
alors je vous laisse imaginer
imaginez une école en pleine nature
entouré d'une forêt proche d'une rivière
sous le soleil du sud de la france sur
un terrain de 40 ha vous pourrez faire
de la permaculture
à côté de cette école imaginer un centre
de formation pour les parents puis un
centre de formation pour les enseignants
et enfin un centre de développement
personnel où on pourrait accueillir des
professionnels qui viendrait donner des
stages des ateliers des formations des
conférences et qui leur permettrait
d'être totalement autonome
le modèle économique en lui-même est
très simple faire en sorte qu'ils aient
plusieurs rapports dans l'école pour
baisser le coût des parents et rendent
ainsi accessibles école à toutes les
couches sociales imaginez une école dans
laquelle les parents sont les bienvenus
accueillis dans un espace qui leur
serait dédié où les professionnels
pourraient les accompagner dans leur
rôle de parents on nous apprend pas et
en imaginer un centre de formation pour
les enseignants
on pourrait proposer des formations
complémentaires à leur cursus des
classiques
tout ceci est possible
alors de la maternelle au bac l'école de
la vie va développer un programme
innovant inspiré de différents courants
comme summer il monte souris steiner
freiner on sait que les êtres humains
sont profondément curieux de découvrir
le monde dans lequel ils vivent
mais également leur monde intérieur nous
mettrons donc à disposition tous les
moyens nécessaires pour les accompagner
dans cette direction des millions de
gens humbles et conscient comme vous et
moi peuvent changer la vie de milliards
d'autres alors soyons changement merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]